[موسيقى]
اخبار المغرب بايجاز اهلا بكم في اقوى
زلزال يشهده المغرب منذ قرن ارتفاع عدد
الضحايا الى اكثر من قتيل ومنظمه الصحه
العالميه تتحدث عن تضرر نحو 300 الف شخص
في منطقه مراكش في حين اعلنت ديوان الملكي
المغربي حدادا وطنيا على ارواح الضحايا
واجراءات عاجله لمساعده متضررين
وسط تحذيرات منهازات ارتداديه اضرار واسعه
في اقليم الحوز ومخاوف من انهيار المباني
المتصدعه حيث قال وزير العد المغربي
للجزيره ان قرن باكملها دمرت في تارودانت
في حين وجهت اليونسكو بعثه للمغرب للوقوف
على المعالم الاثريه التي تضررت جراء
الزلزال مثل هيكل مسجد الكتبيه التاريخي
والمدينه القديمه في مراكش
فرق الانقاذ المغربيه تسابق الزمن للبحث
عن ناجين محتملين من الزلزال المدمر في
حين تسارع الدول لتقديم الدعم للعمليات
حيث توجهت مجموعه الانقاذ القطريه للمناطق
المتضرره محمله باليات مختصه ومساعدات
انسانيه عاجله كما ابدى عدد كبير من دول
العالم والهيئات الدوليه والاقليميه
استعداده لتقديم الدعم والمساعده في
عمليات البحث والانقاذ بينها الاتحاد
الاوروبي والولايات المتحده
تضامن عالمي مع سكان المغرب في ماساتهم
حيث اقام الفلسطينيون صلاه الغائب في
المسجد الاقصى على ارواح ضحايا الزلزال في
حين كشفت تقارير ان النجم البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو قرر فتح فندقه الخاص في
مراكش لايواء المتضررين بينما قرر يوريفا
الوقوف دقيقه صمت في كل المباريات حدادا
على الضحايا واضيئت ابراج لوسيلي في قطر
بعالم المملكه تضامنا مع المغرب الى
اللقاء